hi everybody my name is Jonas Rivera I'm
a producer and the senior vice president
of production at Pixar Animation Studios
and I'm talking to you today from my
home office and I'm here to talk to you
today about Pixar's Easter eggs
[Music]
it's an old tradition at the studio
something we're very proud of it's kind
of appropriate that I'm talking to you
from my home office because my home
office is sort of a living Easter egg I
suppose so ever since a bug's life Pixar
film makers have hidden at least one
Easter egg from an upcoming project in
our films now some of these are fairly
obvious some of them are a little more
subtle and there's lots of different
reasons why and how we've done that and
so we're gonna walk through every single
one from the beginning
[Music]
[Applause]
so a bug's life was our second film came
out in 1998 was the follow-up to Toy
Story and I loved that film I worked on
that film I was the art department
coordinator so I was really involved in
the minutiae and I'd say this is kind of
where the Easter Egg tradition sort of
began right we were just very scrappy
and putting anything we could in that
movie and the specific want to talk
about here cuz it's sort of a so not a
Toy Story - which I hadn't come out yet
was putting woody in one of those funny
little outtakes scenes at the end as a
nod to Toy Story - oh yes
princess hangs about bug's life that's
cool is it's also the first place other
than Toy Story 1 where you see the Pizza
Planet truck and that sort of been this
long-running tradition in terms of the
Pixar Easter eggs we get a lot of credit
for being clever on it but the truth is
in that film we were just more scrappy
than we were clever we just didn't have
a lot of modeling budget to build all
these props we needed for this world and
so I just remember someone pulling the
Pizza Planet truck over from the we
called the digital back lot and using it
at a shot the kind of thinking no one
would notice people noticed and that
became part of our tradition so and I
think bug's life is sort of the point of
origin of this whole conversation
it's another one that's near and dear to
my heart I was the art department
manager on this film and working with
Pete docter kind of for the first time
and we had so much fun putting stuff in
this film and not the film that came out
after that was Finding Nemo so what we
did is we kind of snuck three little
nods to Nemo somewhere a little more
subtle more obvious on this one the
first one if you remember the
Harryhausen's restaurant which of course
Harryhausen's itself is a little Easter
Egg a nod to one of our favorite
animators of all time inside the
restaurant there's murals and we use
kind of the clownfish motif on one of
those murals which was fun there's a
scene in the movie where Randall is
banished out into the world thrown into
some little trailer and on the wall
inside that trailer is if we use the
clownfish model on the walk like it was
caught like a fisherman caught it by the
way that's double prizes because that
trailer is the trailer from a bug's life
we're parked next to the Pizza Planet
truck so that's an easter egg within an
easter egg but my favorite one was at
the end of the movie were where Sullivan
comes back into blues room and he's kind
of putting her her back saying goodbye
and he hands her a bunch of toys one of
which is Jessie but the other one was
literally Nemo
we took the Nemo model that hadn't even
been finished by remember correctly I
think the model was done but hadn't been
articulated and made ready for animation
I think that the character people had to
build one little control of squeezing
because he squeezed him to make a little
squeezy toy sound audience is none the
wiser because of course they haven't
seen Finding Nemo yet but we knew and we
thought that was pretty fun and that
really was the modern first step of the
modern tradition of putting a upcoming
films character or Easter egg in a
current one maybe only speaks whale
[Music]
finding Nemo which came out in 2003 this
is a fun one because it's two-for-one
easter-egg snuck into this film the
first is in the dentist office if you
look really close there's a family way
there's a little Boyd reading a comic
book the cover is an Incredibles comic
so it's a little nod to to what would be
the Incredibles and mr. Incredibles on
there so it's sort of a 2d graphic done
in the art department which we thought
was really cool mr. incredible was added
in it was pretty early I think we were
still working on the Incredibles and the
design was probably still being finessed
but mr. incredible and probably the
whole family wasn't quite ready for
prime time but I think the graphics and
the drawings were so that's why they're
kind of a comic book version in Finding
Nemo because I don't think we usually
especially in those days we didn't have
time to go in and tweak and make a lot
of additions for these things they're
just kind of fun ways to make a nod to
the next film
here's another bonus one I'm gonna give
you that's not a nod but while I'm here
in that dentist office I remember they
wanted you know in dentist office how
you have kind of funny fake plants they
needed to put some plant set dressing in
the dentist office and they took some of
the palm trees from monsters ink that we
used in the world like the weird monster
ease scaled them way down and put them
in little pots so the plants in the
dentist office were actually monster
trees from monsters in but I'm off to
topic let's get back to future Easter
Egg
just like old time Incredibles 2004
Pixar film if you blink you might miss
read the fire truck from the future film
cars actually shows a brief cameo in The
Incredibles read I think sort of fit
Brad's vision of the Incredibles which
is in this kind of 1950s blurry era very
romantic designed world so that's why
he's that thanks this one was a lot of
fun I was working on the film up at the
time and they needed a dog in one of the
montage scenes so the idea was they
wanted to sneak Doug from up what I love
about this one is they did it in a
really clever way because unfortunately
we weren't finished with Doug at the
time his shading and his fern groom and
so forth weren't done so they took Doug
and they just used the model and they
lit it to create the shadow of that
quickly barking as the character runs
through so it's kind of because of that
clever approach is really one of my
favorite one so look close you'll see
the shadow of Doug and ratatouille also
in the apartment if you look close we
snuck in how a little cockroach from
from wall I just kind of run him by
really quickly we figured poor
Linguini's apartment Mike might be the
right place for how to make an
appearance so it's a little nod to who
you'd meet later in wall-e wall-e is
literally a treasure trove of Easter
eggs I mean if you look at Wally's
trailer it's full of stuff it's a little
like the Toy Story for antique mall that
we did years later but one of the
favorite ones of mine in wall-e
again cuz I was working on up at the
time was they took Carl Fredrickson's
you know his cane with the tennis ball
things on the floor
they took his cane and they set dressed
it around there and you can kind of see
it in there twice once when wall-e takes
the magnifier puts it from the iPod
while he's watching the film if you look
just above that you'll see Carl's Walker
and again eye falls off the ceiling of
his truck after it's not there by
later in the film he wali actually
collides with it there so that Walker is
important to us and important to Karl
apparently it's important to Wally
[Music]
UPS very near and dear to my heart I've
produced this first film I produce so
I'm very very proud of that that film
are fun Easter egg in that film my
favourite scene it's when Karl lifts up
and all the balloons fly his house he
goes away he's kind of crashing things
and going through town we cut to a
little girl in her room who's playing
with toys as the house goes by her
window and if you look closely kind of
near her bed almost under her bed you'll
see a sweet little cute pink teddy bear
turns out that's lots of huggin bear who
we'd meet later in Toy Story 3 the
audience doesn't know yet that he's
actually a pretty bad guy but in that
one shot in that sweet little girl's
room he's just a cute little little
Easter egg that we snuck in I actually
got in trouble on this one because I was
there it came up in some conversation
some interview not unlike this talking
about you know when we were getting
ready to launch up people are asking you
know what kind of things have you have
you snuck in you know even back then
they were asking and I said oh you look
close in the little girl's room you'll
see in the little teddy bear it turns
out that's the villain in Toy Story 3 on
camera like 6 months maybe even a year
before Toy Story 3 came I revealed and
spoiled that lots lots so was the
villain lianca which wasn't happy with
me but anyway we didn't hurt the movie I
guess but I felt bad normal ass
[Music]
in 2010 we released Toy Story 3 and in
Andy's room he's got a lot of stuff in
there he's a teenage born now so there's
posters and tchotchkes and things like
that if you look really close you'll see
one of his poster is thin McMissile who
you'll meet later
in cars - also this is a really
interesting one this is a deep cut
because also in Andy's room there's a
little Street Sciences new crossing that
sign is a reference to a film we were
working on at the time a film we decided
to actually not put into production for
various reasons but that little sign is
a nod to a film that was never even made
so that's a real deep cut Easter egg and
you know that happens we we developed
these films and there's so many ideas
that never kind of kind of make it
through the creative process of new-new
it was one of them we all really loved
it and so we're kind of happy that it
lives on a little bit in Andy's room
there's anywhere from three to six films
and various stage of development that
Pixar at any given time and you know
half of them you know come through and
you know half of whom evolved into other
ideas part of the creative process
actually something we're really proud of
you know it's it's not a one-to-one
process we've kind of pride ourselves
and working on these stories and
concepts until we fill their movie
worthy and if for whatever reason they
don't kind of make it to that level you
know we move on and get on to the next
thing so it's just part of our creative
chair
the insult we were missing ROTC cars too
came out in 2011 and we were working on
that film we were also working on brave
which would come out in 2012 so this was
challenged because how do you take
something from the Highlands of Scotland
and put it in the world of cars but we
did it if you look close in ye left turn
in in London during the race
there's the dunbroch family tapestry
that you'll see later in brave only it's
a clarified version you know because
everything in world of cars even the
clouds are somehow clarified so this
tapestry was no different which is kind
of cool little nod to brave
brain was tricky because obviously such
a specific era and location but yet we
worked hard so with monsters University
of mind we had this scene in the witch's
Hut with all the wood carving so if you
look closely you'll see Sullivan and
even though Sullivan from monsters
appeared in the original monsters this
was our nod to monsters University and
also special points you look close
you'll see a wood Pizza Planet truck
kind of hidden away so we had to keep
the traditional alive and brave was a
special channels 2013 monsters
University we had these scare games that
was kind of our opportunity to hide
something in there and this in fact was
the good dinosaur good dinosaur gets two
of these do you look closely we got toy
versions of some of the dinosaurs hidden
in the scare games scene which is kind
of fun they sort of seem to fit the
world and again we had to keep that
tradition alive this is an interesting
one because this is two years before
good dinosaur comes out you'll see these
little toys character show up as toys in
monsters University which is a little
bit of a reminder at how glacial are
processes in animation I mean it takes
about anywhere from four to six years to
make one of these films so we usually
have a long runway which gives us the
ability to kind of put things in
previous films as a matter of fact on
good dinosaur it covers two films
because if I jumped ahead to inside out
another film near and dear to my heart
that's the second film I produced we had
this idea of this scene and inside out
where Riley and her family were driving
from Minnesota to San Francisco and they
needed a couple of places to stop along
the way we thought about that you know
that kind of classic roadside weird
California dinosaur out in the desert
and we thought oh my gosh that's perfect
so we took we took a couple of dinosaur
characters they weren't entirely shaded
but that was fun because we reshape them
as like these kind of crummy looking
concrete things that you'd see in a
roadside and that's where mom and dad
and Riley Park and effect poured dad
lets the brake off and it goes right
through you know that the tail goes
through the window so the good dinosaur
got to be Easter eggs in two films
the good dinosaur came out in 2015 we
were working on finding dory so we had
to find a way to keep the tradition
alive with finding Dory so if you look
close the bottom of water in the good
dinosaur when Arlo is learning to swim
you'll look down there you'll see Hank
Hank the octopus from finding dory Hank
is a really complex character we love
him so much so he got to be our little
nod to finding dory the year later so
Hank is an example of kind of what all
these are it's a little bit of using an
existing model or existing character but
more than that sort of a fun look at
what might be ahead for the audience
2016 we released finding Dory follow-up
to Finding Nemo
this one's really fun because it's maybe
the one of the more saw ones the driver
of the truck that's heading for
Cleveland at dinner film driver has a
band-aid and on that band-aid and you
got to look close it's like a kid's
band-aid an image of Lightning McQueen
it's how it is in my house every time I
need a band-aid it's got some character
picks our character on it so this driver
is the same so the Lightning McQueen
bandaid on his hand is arnaud two cars
three that was coming up the following
year it's fun because I think I don't
know if it's a mix of it gets harder and
harder to sneak these in or if it was
just we try to make it harder I don't
know everyone's gonna probably give you
a different answer on that but
nonetheless it's it's a really fun one
because it's so subtle
[Music]
incarcerate is to to really cool ones
one is Cruz Ramirez who I've loved you
know puts up an image on her display to
motivate kind of the homesick trainee
and that image is the Santa Cecilia you
know gravesite that you'd see later in
cocoa to remind them of home we just
love that set in cocoa and it would seem
like that'd be a place that you yearn
for so it was a kind of a two-for-one
and really work for the story but it was
also kept our tradition alive by showing
a little nod to cocoa there's also the
guitar we stuffed the guitar in which
maybe begs the questions of how cars
might even play a guitar but nonetheless
you know there in the little bar there
at the cotter pin and there's a band
plan so if you look on the wall you'll
see Miguel and the famous silver guitar
from cocoa so it's kind of two dots to
the next year's film cocoa in cars three
[Music]
in 2017 we released Koko a film were
tremendously proud of this was really
fun because this one has a couple in it
there's a scene when Miguel and Hector
are on their way to the land of the dead
for the first time in this city and all
the sets in Coco are so lush they're so
detailed this is a lot of room to kind
of put stuff in and set dress and if you
look really closely there's an
Incredibles poster on one of the walls
which is clearly a nod to the
Incredibles - that was in production but
also in production during cocoa is Toy
Story 4 so if you look closely towards
the beginning I think what Miguel is
kind of running into the plaza for the
first time after he says hi to Dante
there's a rack of pinatas up on one of
the little storefronts there's a buzz
and woody pinata up there those pinatas
are a good example of how you can't just
throw something from one film into
another you have to honor the era you
have to honor the art direction the tone
the setting of the film and so making
pinatas out of buzz and woody was sort
of the perfect example of how that could
work
[Music]
2018 we released Incredibles 2 and at
that time we were working on Toy Story 4
so we wanted to make sure there was a
couple little nods from Toy Story 4 one
of them is seen with the Elastigirl kind
of swing him through the city there's a
billboard that showcases Woody's hat we
had to honor
sheriff woody sort of the epitome of Toy
Story so that was our way to do that
actually I think one of the coolest ones
was a new character is the scene with
Jack Jack he's in his crib in his room
there and we took Duke kaboom the model
of Duke kaboom that no one had met yet
because no one had seen Toy Story 4 and
he's ends up being a little toy in Jack
Jack's crib it's a little quick shot but
we were really happy to see Duke in
there because we love Duke so much I
think Duke also sort of fit the world an
era of The Incredibles because in our
minds Duke is sort of a late 60s early
70s kind of toy that we might have had
and so I think Brad felt he was he was a
good fit for a little Jack Jack so you
think you meet him in Toy Story 4 but he
actually shows up in Incredibles 2 first
let's talk about the theory that comes
up when we often talk about this and I
think the Duke kaboom Easter egg and
Incredibles helped amplify this if
people ask us is the fact that Jack Jack
do kaboom toy proof that all the Pixar
films take place in one universe you
know comes up enough I once asked Andrew
Stanton what's your take Andrew with the
all the films take place in one universe
he said are you kidding you think we're
that smart there's no way - there's no
way that we would be that clever - do it
let the fans think it and and and kind
of draw their own conclusions and so
that's kind of our take it's really just
us being scrappy and having a little bit
of fun but we kind of like that it's
growing into it's its own thing you know
for key 2019 we released Toy Story 4 I'm
very proud of that films it's the third
film I got to produce and work with an
amazing crew it was really fun on that
picture because you have these amazing
sets that were just right for Easter
eggs you have the antique mall which has
everything in it something from every
single Pixar film even the shorts and
then you had the carnival and that's
where we decided we should have our
forward-facing Easter eggs so one of the
things we did because gala Hall are
working on onward we loved honored so
much that we loved that dan you know
Barley's fan with that amazing Pegasus
painting we asked if we could take that
painting and we transposed it onto the
bounce house that's part of the carnival
you know where the toys are in the third
act there so if you look close you'll
see Barley's van painting on a downtown
square for whatever reason we thought it
should be once we put these Easter eggs
in we have to deal with the fact that
our films continue to change and get cut
and added things and so forth and so
yeah once they're in it doesn't mean
they're locked in we still have to roll
with the creative punches on these
things and but we always have made sure
that they show up one one way or another
and of course it started in Toy Story 1
you know the Pizza Planet truck and so
we obviously had to put it in Toy Story
4 but we didn't want to be so obvious
because it just felt like it's somehow
found its way into every film so we had
to really rethink it so he came up with
us I think it was Josh Cooley I don't
remember who came up with this idea but
the Toy Story 4 version of the Pizza
Planet truck is actually seen on a
really ugly calf tattoo on the carnival
worker that is you know Manning the
carnival booth
where duckie and bunny are from and it's
really quick but for some reason that
carnival worker has a tattoo of the
Pizza Planet truck on his leg we were
really proud of ourselves with that one
for some reason the character's name was
Axl after our editor Axl geddens is
voiced by Bill Hader which is funny
because he barely even has a line we
basically hired Bill Hader who we love
and is a friend of ours from inside out
to say what's the line the lines like
you know something he says nothing but
it's Bill Hader back to life that's not
possible it is with this while we were
making on word of course the film that
didn't production down the hall is soul
that hasn't even been released yet but
we had to make sure that we had a little
bit of soul in our own words so in the
family kitchen if you look closer the
cult kind of comes in and you know
knocks everything down it sits down
there there's some records on the table
that I feel a close that's Dorothea
Williams record and everybody knows
Dorothea Williams is the famous jazz
singer that everyone loves in the movie
soul so it's a forward nod to the world
of soul I think the truth about all of
these Easter eggs that point forward is
they're really just a little fun wing of
the audience something that they don't
even know they're seeing but what we
hope with all of our films is that
people watch them multiple times over
over over time and people grow up with
them and families enjoy them and so
what's fun is that helps them age well
in a way is that you'll go see Seoul and
you'll see Dorothea Williams you might
want your rewatching on where our hope
is you oh my gosh look at that little
that it deepens the experience in some
way it's not necessarily anything that
we put a ton of storytelling around it's
not like we're leaving clues to what the
narrative is going to be it's more just
a fun wrapper for the audience and
something fun for our crews to put into
these these pictures there are more
future facing Easter eggs we're pretty
sure if you look
find them
[Music]
that was about every future
forward-facing Easter egg and a Pixar
movie that I could think that's a lot of
them I hope you enjoyed it and I hope
you stayed tuned because we got a lot of
new movies coming out with a lot of new
forward-facing Easter eggs and they're
gonna be fun to keep looking I promise
you we'll keep the tradition alive so
thank you so much for for watching and
enjoy